Transcription: Karen Henry
Relecteur: eric vautier
À la fin de la guerre de Corée en 1953,
les responsables coréens
se sont retrouvés,
se sont assis devant un pays
qui a été démoli par la guerre.
Ils réfléchissaient à leur avenir.
Les responsables coréens avaient le choix.
Ils avaient la possibilité
de repenser leur pays,
en partant du principe qu’ils n’allaient
pas être financés pour avancer.
Ils se sont regardés
avec un objectif bien précis :
« Que devons-nous faire en ce moment bien
précis pour l’avenir de notre pays ? »
Là, ils ont décidé d’investir tout
ce qu’ils avaient dans l’éducation.
La Corée n’est pas un pays riche
en ressources naturelles.
La Corée n’était pas
une puissance économique
qui pouvait peser sur sa puissance
extérieure pour gagner de l’argent.
C’était un simple pays qui a été colonisé
et détruit par une guerre civile.
Aujourd’hui, la Corée est
un exemple au niveau économique,
un exemple démocratique, un exemple
de puissance et de développement.
Ils ont tout misé sur l’éducation.
C’était ma première histoire.
Quand j’étais petit,
j’ai toujours pensé que j’étais stupide.
L’école ne marchait pas beaucoup
pour moi entre six et douze ans.
Ce n’était pas du tout ça
pour moi à l’école.
Heureusement, j’avais un père -
Entre temps, il y a eu un événement
qui a tout chamboulé.
J’étais un élève assez calme,
mais j’arrivais à suivre.
Ma mère est partie à l’étranger
quand j’avais à six ans.
J’y étais beaucoup attaché, ce qui
fait que ça m’a beaucoup déstabilisé.
Je n’ai pas pu suivre
le cursus comme il fallait.
A partir de ce moment-là,
j’ai commencé à très mal travailler.
Je n’étais pas un élève
qui arrivait à bien suivre les cours,
mais je ne comprenais pas pourquoi.
Heureusement,
j’avais un père bienveillant,
beaucoup dans les sciences sociales,
qui a su que ce qu’il me fallait
à ce moment-là, c’était de la sérénité
et me faire croire [en moi].
J’ai eu la chance de grandir avec un père
comme ça, qui m’a toujours encouragé.
Quand j’allais à l’école, j’avais la
moyenne la plus basse de la classe.
Je lui disais : « Mes camarades
se sont moqués de moi. »
Il me disait : « Ils se moquent car ils
ont peur, tu es le plus intelligent. »
Je disais : « Comment ça se fait alors
que je n’arrive pas à travailler ? »
Finalement c’est après
que j’ai découvert qu’en fait,
cette petite voix qui est en nous,
qui nous donne de la confiance,
c’est une petite voix
qu’on entend des autres.
Moi, ça m’a permis de grandir.
Je me souviens du moment du déclic.
J’étais en classe, j’étais en CM1.
On a fait un devoir en classe.
Le prof est venu en classe,
il était énervé.
Il était vraiment fâché
contre tout le monde :
« Vous avez mal travaillé,
c’est insupportable.
Un seul élève a fait
quelque chose qui m’a rendu fier,
c’est Djawad. »
Je l’ai regardé :
« Qu’est-ce qu’il s’est passé ? »
J’avais eu la meilleure moyenne,
ce jour-là, à ce contrôle,
et je ne comprenais pas comment.
Et depuis, je me suis toujours dit :
« Mon père avait raison en me disant
que j’étais le meilleur, je peux tenir. »
J’ai toujours essayé depuis.
J’ai eu la chance entre temps
de partir faire mes études en Malaisie.
Depuis, j’ai toujours eu cet amour de la
connaissance, à aller vouloir la chercher.
J’ai fini mes études après cinq ans ;
c’était le moment pour moi de rentrer.
En revenant aux Comores, je me disais que
je laissais un pays comme la Malaisie,
un pays que j’ai vu grandir,
que j’ai vu se développer.
Je vais rentrer chez moi,
il va falloir que je puisse mettre à
disposition tout ce que j’aurai appris
chez moi, au pays.
Mais je sens que j’ai encore faim,
le buffet n’est pas encore fini,
et j’ai envie d’apprendre beaucoup plus.
Donc je me suis développé
un système où, partout où j’allais,
quand je montais dans un taxi,
un bus ou un train,
je discutais avec les différentes
personnes que je rencontrais.
Un jour, je suis monté dans un taxi ;
c’était un vieux Chinois qui conduisait.
Je lui ai posé la question :
« Je suis un enfant des îles Comores.
J’ai fait cinq ans en Malaisie,
je vais rentrer chez moi.
Quel est le conseil que tu pourrais
me donner avant de rentrer ?
Ainsi, je ne t’oublierai jamais ;
je me rappellerai ce que tu m’as dit. »
Il m’a regardé avec un air très joyeux.
Je sentais que la question
l’avait vraiment touché.
Il m’a dit : « La première des choses,
garde cette curiosité, ne change pas.
Si tu arrives à garder ça,
de maintenant jusqu’à la fin de tes jours,
tu ne vas pas t’arrêter de grandir.
Tu pourras réaliser de grandes choses. »
La deuxième chose est
quelque chose de très profond.
Il m’a dit : « Jeune homme, quand tu pars
chez toi, ne cours pas derrière l’argent.
Essaye de changer les choses,
fais-les comme il faut, sois correct.
Ne cours pas derrière l’argent parce que
tu vas toujours finir parmi les derniers
et ne feras pas ce que tu veux
si tu le cherches.
L’argent, il est partout, tu vas le
trouver, mais ne cours pas derrière. »
Ça m’a beaucoup marqué
et ça m’a donné cette envie.
Ça m’a beaucoup fait réfléchir.
Je me suis dit : « Je rentre chez moi,
il y a beaucoup de problèmes. »
Je rentrais avec
un état d’esprit entrepreneurial.
L’entrepreneur, le milieu où il est le
mieux, c’est un milieu avec des problèmes.
Mon pays avait pas mal de problèmes,
donc je me suis dit qu’il fallait
d’abord que je ramène le sourire.
C’est comme si j’étais un chercheur d’or
et que j’arrivais dans le pays
où il y a le plus d’or au monde.
Je suis heureux, mais je dois installer
les machines pour extraire cette richesse.
En revenant aux Comores,
il y avait beaucoup de challenges.
Et, Dieu merci, deux ans après, je suis
tombé amoureux du secteur de l’éducation.
C’est là où je devais et pouvais
faire quelque chose.
Parce qu’entre temps,
j’ai acquis pas mal de connaissances.
J’ai gagné en sérénité et j’avais
une vision claire que, pour moi,
sans une éducation de qualité,
le continent africain ne se relèvera pas,
ne pourra pas tenir ses responsabilités.
Nous sommes une génération -
La vie, c’est un relais.
Chaque génération doit recevoir
son témoin de l’autre génération
et pouvoir le transmettre.
Ce n'est pas à nous de finir la course.
On a le témoin qui nous
donne une responsabilité
et qu’on doit porter
à la prochaine génération.
C’est à se demander
quelle est notre responsabilité
dans ce qui se passe maintenant
pour notre génération.
Frantz Fanon disait : « Chaque
génération doit, en toute opacité,
découvrir sa mission,
la remplir ou la trahir. »
On peut se poser la question :
« Quelle est la mission
qui incombe à notre génération ? »
Chacun pourra observer cette question
selon les angles de lecture
qu’il pense logiques.
L’éducation est un secteur
qu’on ne peut pas négliger,
il faut faire quelque chose.
Mais il ne suffit pas d’investir
et d’ouvrir des écoles.
Il va falloir réfléchir
et réinventer nos instituts éducatifs
et notre système éducatif
pour pouvoir donner aux Africains
la possibilité de s’émanciper
et de faire des choses qui vont vraiment
bénéficier au continent et à nos pays.
Mais comme on dit, il faut
penser global, mais agir local.
Aujourd’hui, j’aimerais dire à la jeunesse
africaine et à la jeunesse comorienne
qu’il ne faut pas se renfermer
sur nos îles ou un seul pays.
Il faut penser d’abord continental.
On a ce devoir de penser continental
parce que nos pères fondateurs -
quand je pense à Jerry Rawlings,
quand je pense à Thomas Sankara,
quand je pense à Nyerere,
tous ces gens se sont retrouvés
à l’Union africaine la première fois,
ils se sont dit que nous devions
nous unir d’abord, penser africain,
avant de penser à nos pays.
D’ailleurs, Kwame Nkrumah,
le président du Ghana,
sa première déclaration
après l’indépendance,
le premier pays africain
à avoir pris son indépendance,
disait à son peuple :
« Permettez-moi, s’il vous plaît,
de ne pas prendre
la charge du Ghana d’abord,
mais d’aider nos autres frères africains
à se libérer afin d’être égaux.
Mais s’il n’y a que nous,
on n’est pas encore libres. »
Aujourd’hui, il faut penser
à l’éducation en Afrique,
regagner notre place, reprendre
la responsabilité qui nous incombe,
qui est d’éduquer nos enfants
comme on veut, quand on veut,
exactement avec notre
propre système éducatif.
Jusqu’à maintenant,
ça a été du copier-coller.
Aujourd’hui, dans l’éducation aux Comores,
j’ai décidé d’ouvrir
une institution éducative,
de réinventer l’école
adaptée à notre culture,
à notre religion, à notre vision,
à nos aspirations futures,
et pouvoir dire que nous faisons quelque
chose - voilà ce qui devait se faire.
Notre approche a été de nous demander
pourquoi nous enseignons,
pourquoi nous ouvrons
ces institutions éducatives.
Et justement, ce n’est pas
pour préparer des intellectuels,
ce n’est pas pour préparer des gens
qui vont travailler demain,
mais tout d’abord, c’est de préparer des
humains qui sauront vivre ensemble,
qui sauront prendre avec intégrité
les responsabilités qui leur incombent
et ne pas faire comme tout
ce qui a été fait jusqu’à aujourd’hui.
On peut se demander comment.
Le problème de l’Afrique, c’est que,
même si les écoles sont là,
non seulement il n’y a pas
assez d’écoles en Afrique -
dans l’éducation tertiaire ou de la petite
enfance, il n’y a pas assez d’écoles -
mais comment donner cette éducation
à des gens qui n’ont pas les moyens ?
Il fallait donc adapter le comment
de ces instituts pour pouvoir survivre
en donnant une éducation de qualité.
Donc il fallait repenser tout ça.
Pour répondre à cette question,
on a fait le « pourquoi ? »
C’est pouvoir dans un premier temps
faire des hommes intègres
avec des valeurs humaines et sociales.
Deuxièmement, faire des citoyens du monde,
des enfants qui sauront s’adapter partout
en leur donnant des langues,
de la culture générale,
pour connaître la réalité
du monde qui les entoure,
car aujourd’hui, ce n’est plus
la même vision qu’il y a dix ans,
Donner cet amour et cette responsabilité
de l’environnement et de la nature
qui est un des enjeux sur toutes
les tables des négociations du monde.
On parle de réchauffement climatique
et des différents problèmes
liés à l’environnement.
Leur donner ces responsabilités.
Le dernier, c’est très important :
l’inclusion.
Aujourd’hui, on ne peut pas penser
l’éducation en Afrique ou aux Comores
pour un seul groupe, en excluant
les enfants qui souffrent de handicap,
les enfants qui n’ont pas
les moyens d’apprendre,
et qui ne vont pas bénéficier
d’une éducation de qualité.
On ne peut pas.
Si on pense à une éducation de qualité,
on va inclure tout le monde.
Être sûr que tout le monde va en
bénéficier, donner sa chance à tous.
L’institution que j’ai co-fondée
avec ma partenaire et mon épouse,
Hope school, c’est une école où on a
réinventé l’éducation dans tout son sens.
Dans un premier temps,
nous sommes une école islamique.
On est dans un pays musulman.
Nous avons instauré cet aspect islamique :
la madrasa est à l’intérieur de l’école.
Nous sommes une école
multilingue où les enfants
vont apprendre plusieurs langues
tout au long de leur vie.
C’est-à-dire qu’aujourd’hui
nos enfants vont apprendre en anglais,
en arabe et en français.
Je ne parle pas de secondes langues.
Ce sont des immersions
une semaine entièrement en anglais.
Tout ce qu’ils vont faire,
les calculs, la culture,
les activités, ça va être en anglais,
et la semaine qui va suivre,
ça va être purement en arabe.
Et ainsi de suite, ça va être
le swahili, ça va être l’espagnol.
Leur donner les outils pour que,
plus tard, ils acquièrent des langues.
Avec l’objectif que nos enfants
soient polyglottes :
au minimum dix langues
quand ils auront dix ans.
3e aspect, nous sommes une école verte
avec 250 m² dédiés à l’agriculture,
à la permaculture, au tri, à l’écologie.
On est une école inclusive
où tous les enfants ont leur place.
Un enfant souffrant
de différents handicaps,
psychologiques ou physiques, a sa place.
Malheureusement, il faut savoir
que dans le monde,
pour donner un exemple,
un enfant trisomique sur sept
ne va pas bénéficier d’une éducation.
Un enfant sur sept.
Il faut savoir que le système
classique qu’on utilise aujourd’hui,
il a été fondé à un moment
où on n’avait pas assez d’informations
sur comment le cerveau humain fonctionne,
comment il peut apprendre,
et on perpétue malheureusement ce système.
Mais il faudrait dire : « Stop !
Maintenant nous allons changer. »
Comment ça va se faire ?
En acceptant qu’aujourd’hui,
la connaissance n’a pas besoin
d’aller dans une salle de classe fermée,
avec un enseignant qui en a
le monopole et qui va la transmettre.
La connaissance est partout.
La connaissance est dans un film,
dans un documentaire,
dans une discussion avec un ami,
avec un parent,
dans une discussion
avec une copine, avec un copain.
Partout où tu es,
tu peux avoir la connaissance.
Donner accès à la connaissance,
ce n’est pas la renfermer,
mais c’est de la donner
aux jeunes, leur dire :
« Vous allez pouvoir apprendre.
Il suffit juste d’avoir cet état d’esprit
que vous êtes un apprenant à vie.
Partout où vous êtes, vous devez
apprendre, vous pouvez apprendre.
La connaissance ne va jamais s’arrêter. »
Pour conclure, j’aimerais finir
par une citation d’un très grand sage,
Pierre Rabhi, franco-algérien,
qui disait :
« Il ne suffit pas de se demander quelle
planète nous allons laisser à nos enfants.
Il faut aussi se demander quels enfants
nous allons laisser à notre planète. »